auf der erste teil ist eigentlich nur
der zielwurf wo man 43 hat bei denen sie
jeweils einen innen und einen außen gilt
und genauso die punkteverteilung dann
noch ist also trifft man alle würfe in
den innenkreis 136 punkte der zweite
teil ist dann der weitwurf wo man drei
würfe hat und der weiteste gezählt wird
um diese punkte werden alle
zusammengerechnet und vergeben dann den
gesamt unterstand für das werfen
perfekt sie wurde noch mal sehr präzise
gewesen sehr fokussiert gewesen und beim
weitwurf ist natürlich gelaufen aber das
gesamtergebnis ist äußerst
zufriedenstellend und somit können mit
dem werfen sehr positiv abschließen